the attitude of Americans to people that
drink Drive is like you'll be at some
bar oh we're going to go to such and
such a place do you want to come I was
oh presuming that there's Uber waiting
outside and someone gets into their Ford
F150 go I've just watched you sink Three
Margaritas over the last hour no one
really bats an eye great video of when
they first introduced the you can't
drink and drive drink and drive not
drink then drive you can't drink and
drive and they're talking to these guys
and girls from the deep south in America
and they're all in beat up Chevy trucks
they're interviewing them through the
window and this dude sat there and
there's another one with a woman who sat
there child on passenger seat without
seat belt on beer between legs saying I
don't know what this country is coming
to that a guy can't finish his hard day
at work have a beer when he's on his way
home this country is being run by
Communists these godamn commies trying
to take our beers away from us and I'm
like you're drinking and driving